I do believe that there that people are
more Lonesome than they were they're
more socially isolated yeah I'm loath to
make intergenerational comparisons you
know because every generation thinks
that this current Young Generation is
worse than any generation that's ever
existed what is better and what
and worse than ever right now
in our culture
we have no idea what this intense focus
on social media
is doing to everyone but particularly to
young people I mean can you imagine
that nothing you ever did with as a
teenager could be forgotten awful I live
in a world where people have said
horrible things about me on the internet
and on social media yeah that's funny
yeah it's so funny I know you have a lot
of experience with that but I don't know
them so I can write that off to they
don't even know me right but now this
happens in school and a kid can read
this and and they they're in class with
that person or they they have a Locker
near them and I think that that is such
a dangerous and horrible thing for a kid
to have to deal with I very much
empathize with kids today and social
media so there's a there's a female
pattern of anti-social behavior and
there's a male pattern of anti-social
Behavior
and the male pattern of anti-social
behavior is a lot more physically
violent the female pattern of
anti-social behavior is reputation
destruction
and it scales on the internet the
physical aggression doesn't right right
what can you do right it's limited and
I'm not saying it's not serious it can
obviously be mortally serious right it's
serious
but it does characterize it a small
minority of men especially
consistently wow but female anti-social
Behavior which is almost never discussed
there's a large research literature on
it because people have wondered you know
that if you look at boys and girls for
example
two-year-olds I mentioned them some
two-year-olds are aggressive and that's
by Nature mostly
okay so they kick hit bite and steal in
groups of two-year-olds now they're not
very harmful because they're two but if
it doesn't if it isn't socialized it
turns into conduct disorder and that
turns into antisocial and criminal
Behavior that's what happens so most
people who are Criminal by the time
they're 18 were aggressive when they
were two and weren't socialized okay so
now most of those aggressive
two-year-olds are boys
if you define aggression by hitting
kicking stealing and biting but the
reputation destruction that starts early
with girls and that's their form of
anti-social behavior and you know we
don't know what political manifestation
female anti-social Behavior will produce
because the
complete immersement of men and women in
the political realm is new
but for to think that it'll be nothing
well you have to be a complete bloody
fool to think that because obviously the
Dark Side of men has a dark political
Edge why wouldn't the Dark Side of women
have a dark political Edge
but I can't help seeing it I see it I
think that's the reputation destruction
that's characteristic of social media
seems to be I mean I saw when girls went
after my daughter in particular when she
was a teenager bullying on on social
media they use reputation destruction
and it can be unbelievably vicious while
you said you've been attacked plenty
online it's also possible that
you know there's a large proportion of
men who use reputation destruction too
online
so I wouldn't say that this is something
limited to women by any stretch of the
imagination but I do know that those two
patterns of anti-social Behavior exist
so and that one doesn't scale so that is
a relevant issue you were talking about
asked about body image or commented on
body image you know a lot of people
think that that's a consequence of
social pressure
body image trouble and I don't think
there's any evidence for that by the way
really yeah well a lot of so
women are more likely to have body image
problems than men right okay so that's
the first thing
so and that's likely because
body morphology is more important in
mating choice
for women than it is for men
tend to prefer women who show signs of
fertility that's associated with youth
and symmetry so symmetry is very very
important as as a marker of beauty so we
tend to see symmetrical faces as
beautiful waist to hip ratio 0.68 that
seems to be relatively standard
culturally regardless of body size and
that's also that's associated with
cardiovascular health and with fertility
and so
there's an ideal
idealized ideal female morphology and
any deviation from that causes upset and
women are more prone to negative emotion
than men not anger by the way
that's that's a tougher One But anxiety
and pain related emotions women are more
sensitive to those than men maybe
because they're smaller and life is more
dangerous to them and they have to be
more threat sensitive maybe because they
take care of infants
and so you know one question I've never
discussed this I don't think on online
women become more sensitive to negative
emotion than men when they hit puberty
not before
and it never goes away after that right
so it's a permanent transformation even
after menopause just like yeah well the
men and women get more stable
emotionally as they get older but the
difference between men and women doesn't
seem to attenuate
and so I've now women became such become
sexually vulnerable at puberty so that
might be one reason why they would be
more sensitive to Danger right yeah
right I mean there's plenty of places in
the world where you wouldn't Walk Alone
sure right there's there's plenty of
places where walking alone would make
you a valid Target even right right
right and I would say that's probably
more the norm for human societies than
the exception
you know we assume that our relatively
safe
environments are normal they're not they
took a lot of work to get safe like so
much work that it's almost
incomprehensible there's just so many
things we take for granted that make up
that safety that that are invisible
because because it's mostly there
but I also wonder possibly if women's
nervous systems are optimized for the
woman child dyad and not for the woman
so imagine that well if you have a baby
you're definitely more vulnerable
right right and so perhaps your nervous
system should reflect that because
you're the one making the decisions and
you know because women are more prone to
anxiety disorders and depression than
men that seems true cross-culture and it
goes along with that sensitivity to
negative emotion you think what's the
advantage to that because it causes a
lot of suffering it's also a good promo
predictor of marital instability because
higher levels of negative motion predict
well unhappiness it's certainly possible
that women's nervous systems adult
women's are are optimized for the for
the child for the infant mother diet
I mean why would we expect it to be
other than that you know because a baby
is so unbelievably dependent you have to
be more cautious once you have an infant
especially one under one years old what
are the positives of anxiety well you're
more likely to stay away from danger
[Music]